right here now on the outset of his
fourth season in the nfl
after that breakout 2020 season from the
green bay packers
tight end robert big bobby tonyan
right here on the rich eisen show how
are you sir how's it going rich
did i nail your last name correct did i
get your last absolutely it's tuning
right better
it's tonya right yes sir rhymes with
funyun
is that how basically it is yep okay yes
all right because i was blowing it all
the way up until the middle of last
season when
suddenly somebody says to me it's not
tonyan it's tonyan so i want to get that
right
i appreciate it okay and is it robert or
bob or because you know that's because
kittle keeps referring to you as big
bobby tonyan is what he keeps saying i
just want to make sure i get this right
yeah yeah i'm robert my dad's robert my
grandpa's robert so we've been called
everything any nickname just to kind of
tell us apart so
anything i'll respond to okay um big
bobby tonyan here on the rich eisen show
cause that's what kittle calls you how
long
when did you first meet george uh i met
george down in pre-draft training in
frisco texas we pre-drive train together
uh we had the same agent so yeah we were
down at the
frisco exos um down and what was that
2017.
so you met because you have the same
agent is that basically yep okay
yep okay and you remember being there
for my 40 yard dash i assume
right oh yeah robert lightning speed i
barely saw you running
[Laughter]
that's understandable that's totally
understandable but uh you know
and then this season happened what what
did happen for you
last year what do you got i mean
the the packers offense was sitting on
all cylinders and
um you know i worked my way into the
starting role at tight end and you know
thankful to and grateful to be a part of
that offense and just did my part and
you know it worked out for me and it
worked out for the team
how do you work your way in what walk me
through that process
robert just putting your head down and
working uh asking questions of the vets
just
observing listening learning the past
three years behind
uh jimmy graham and mercedes lewis and
then obviously getting a good connection
with aaron and
once my time came just not looking back
and just
taking every opportunity you know and
just rolling with it
and just not having any moment too big
and too little just keeping
you know a mental flow state throughout
the season
of highs and lows and just putting my
head down and working
and so it just dawned on you
hey i'm getting a little more playing
time here or your name gets called a
little bit more for you to get out in
the field i mean
or does uh the floor or your position
last year
last year i think coming off of covet
and coming off of a
surgery i just had a lot to prove and uh
with jimmy
uh graham leaving the packers i there
was just an open spot in the
tight end room and i wanted to be that
guy i wanted to be
the tight end for the green bay packers
and i just went out there and did it
and we were successful on offense and i
was glad to be a part of that
and then just look just in terms of your
journey um you
how did you wind up at indiana state how
did that happen
uh i was a quarterback my first two
years there i was a quarterback in my
last three years there i was a receiver
um yeah i was i was a small town
quarterback in high school
had you know a lot of you know d1 double
a offers
in indiana state i the coach there was
trent miles he recruited me heavily
there i got a good relationship
with him through that process and went
to indiana state and
it was awesome well what type of
quarterback were you
walk me through your game as a
quarterback i thought i was going to be
the next cam newton that was like i was
a peyton manning fan growing up and
i loved watching cam newton and uh
i thought i was dual threat i probably
was a little less athletic than i really
thought i was right
i like to get out there and run around
and throw the rock
so how how far can you throw one i mean
what what's the
what's the max distance of uh oh robert
tanyan throwing up
who right now right now probably around
65.
probably right now what does that mean
right now
so what was your max throw at some point
come on
i'd probably get closer to 70. i
probably wouldn't even be able to throw
65 to be honest with you rich right now
my shoulder might explode
okay but is is it possible for lefleur
to maybe draw something up where
where you're you're you get one from
behind the line of scrimmage and
and and you never know what that offense
you never know what that offense we got
a bunch of stuff going
back and forth crisscrossing so you
never know what could happen
okay we call call it a funyun special
you know anybody think
you know i'm just i'll give him i'll
give you his number
make that call oh by the way i'll take
that number um
so one of the reasons why i ask you your
your origin story robert tunion is
because
in the times that i have spoken aaron
rodgers um
you know on this show he does seem to
have an encyclopedic knowledge
of every single person's journey that
he's throwing to
or that he is in the huddle with he
knows everybody's history
he knows everybody's chip on their
shoulder
and he's also there to uh foster that
in some way shape or form what has your
relationship
been like with him robert um
just from just from day one i think that
he saw
how hungry i was and i just want to be
great
i've always wanted to be great i don't
want to be middle of the pack i don't
ever want to be sugar coated with
coaching or
a coaching point or someone trying to
change my game
i just want to be told straight up what
i have to get better at or if that was
good enough
and for him to know how coachable i am
and how great i want to be
he's just always been on me and never
let me you know
stoop below you know that mentality and
he's always been like that
with me from day one and obviously the
friendship
off the field keeps growing where um you
know you could see him you know getting
after me a little bit on the field but
that's just
the competitive nature of both of us
that um
he wants me to be there for him and you
know i want to be there for him on the
field so
whatever it is you know we're not going
to get sensitive
on the field if he's coaching me or
getting after me the whole point is to
win a super bowl
and as long as we're on the same page
with that you know feelings aren't going
to get in the way
give me a few details on what getting
after you is
and what it's like and how it feels to
be on the receiving end of that
what is that um just i mean
just like anyone who is you know like
more so like a coach you know when they
get after you it's more at you and
with him it's more like i need you
to do this or i need to do that which
in retrospect if there needs something
it's because that's what's gonna do
to win this game and you just have to
look at the bigger picture not take it
personal that someone's trying to make
you better or
change a player you know get after
something that you did wrong
or possibly just a little off from what
they want
and um yeah just not taking anything
really sensitive and just
rolling with it and learning from it and
going out there making to play the next
time and
and then everyone forgets about it now
look i know that you're
you know you don't speak for the man and
and as you know
um his situation which is the way we put
it in
in sports business and sports media um
is it literally at the forefront of
everybody's mind i mean he he
he he calls in to wish his buddy kenny
mayne a farewell
he has a minute-long soliloquy on the
organization
and people being a part of it in green
bay and it's just
it goes like a house of fire is there
anything you could tell us
about what aaron's mindset is
and return possibility of the green bay
packers could be
robert tanyan uh i just
like any other of my teammates or you
know my close friends on the team
like i stay in contact with them through
you know the off season when we aren't
together and
uh what we talk about is we don't talk
about football we talk about
if we're you know mentally and
spiritually you know good growing
you know just making sure my friend's
alright uh
making sure you know mentally he's
saying
doing well i mean obviously he is fine
he's a grown man and he
he handle handles his business well but
uh the conversations that me and him
have are just mostly based on that how
are we doing
you know off the field and just making
sure that we're good
and our spirits are high and
all that stuff nothing really about
football or business
um you know that's not a part of our
friendship and
we just leave that to the business man
so um
how many people come up to you and say
hey you must be every single
human being you come across you know ask
you do you think he's coming back or not
i mean you must get that all the time
yeah i probably get it yeah probably
every day but you know
am i the first one today am i the first
one today robert
uh you might be yeah it is it's about 11
20 here
i feel like i'm on instagram what people
say first is a comment you know i'm
hey i'm first today so i guess
what do you think do you are you
concerned because again
it's difficult because that that could
be read like you know you you're you're
not a fan of jordan love and i don't
want that to come across that way either
um so what um i just think that it's a
business thing that
obviously i mean aaron's been the
quarterback of the green bay packers for
16 years
uh i've been a tight end for four years
i think that's above my pay grade and
you know like you said i don't want to
talk for him and all that stuff and
i think that's just a business thing um
i'm just gonna continue to get better
and play tight end for the green bay
packers and
if when or whatever happens and aaron
comes back i'm ready and
um there's no gray area with me i'm
ready to hit the ground running and win
a super bowl when
whenever he's back how can you uh best
you can tell
how jordan love is handling all of this
right now
in practice otas he's doing well he's i
mean it's
it's a good time for him to uh you know
be
control the huddle be there at practice
and get those reps that he didn't get
last year and um it's kind of letting
him run the show and see where he's at
and
uh throw at the guys and uh he's doing
well
i mean jordan's been is a good kid um
he's a lot out in front of him so
i don't think a lot of i think a lot of
the players don't even think about it
when we're actually
at practice or at green bay it's otas
it's optional
um so guys are here and there so i think
that the guys who are there just worry
about getting better
and i think that's what's special about
this team is the distractions and
adversity
don't really you know strike us we just
kind of face it and
just keep working keep getting better
and day by day just keep building blocks
and
whatever happens you know we'll be ready
so
you're it's not on your mind as you're
out there on the field uh
i do the only thing is i was just
kind of telling some of the guys there i
mean that's just with any teammate
who's important to you um
who's ever important to you um
you want them there you just want them
there in in the cafeteria you want them
they're in the locker room you want them
there just like
talking and just being around them i
think that's any teammate
but necessarily you're not just thinking
about
the whole situation the whole process i
think we're just missing our teammate
robert tunion here uh on the rich eisen
show okay so
how much better do you think you can get
here like what's your goal would you get
stuff written down
did you do a goal right down
my goals down see them on my wall every
day
um i obviously want to set more
lofty goals than last year i um
you know went past my goals so i want to
set more lofty goals
but also at the same time i just want to
continue to progress as a player
progress as a man every day um get
better at leadership and contr
and just kind of mold myself into a you
know a more
bigger role in that aspect but on the
field wise i just want to keep getting
better
keep progressing in the run game um you
know work on
whatever it needs to do to get the ball
and just
win games i just want to win a super
bowl so bad and
i've explained that with matt and
we're on the same page that i just want
to progress and put myself in a
position to just take this team to an uh
another new level
and just add add more to the offense so
11 touchdowns surpassed what you had on
your
what what is it on yo is it a grease
board where do you keep it it's a cork
board
i just had a i just had a not just like
a poster i just wrote it down in sharpie
like a check box okay goals in the
morning right
right next to like my keys in the
morning so i see it every
morning so you don't forget your goals
or your keys all right put your wallet
there your cell phone
um and uh so what are your goals this
year
you you got them you wanna can you share
them what do you got i don't i do not
have any statistical goals yet
okay um but you know just
em embracing me and um just becoming a
better man every day
is my personal goal right now in this
offseason is just to
kind of take in and hone a mindset that
of what i did last year is me it's not a
it's not a
fluke it wasn't just a one season i
wasn't lucky like that's what i stand on
i stand on my
hard work i stand on my determination
and and i want to win
just as much as anyone in that locker
room and i feel like
getting everyone on that page the in the
leadership role that i want to take on
and
getting everyone in that mental state of
that we can do this and
just making everyone feel comfortable
and confident in themselves i think that
once everyone is on that same page that
the green bay packers um are limitless
so uh before i let you go um first of
all
feel free to check appearing on the rich
eyes and show off that list
on your board okay
please um and then you'll be checking
off uh
attending tight end university in june
correct you're going
oh yeah okay live down there so i'll
already be down there waiting okay
so what is it what yeah i mean i asked
george about the curriculum
i told him i would be more than happy to
film a video welcoming everybody
to each daily event like what what do
you got what what is it going to be
do you know what yeah what it's gonna be
i think it's just uh
yeah it's just uh you know the tight
ends across the
across the league getting together just
sharing their
mentality sharing their game sharing
going over film with each other
um just seeing you know the work ethic
of everyone across the league and just
kind of just making a fraternity like a
brotherhood of the tight ends that
you know we've been underappreciated as
a
position over the years and i think that
now that the tight end isn't coming more
to light
than getting everyone together and just
embracing each other and enjoying
you know a long weekend of work and and
fun would just be good for the guys and
uh just pick brains of you know like
travis
and obviously i get to pick george's
brain every day but
you know of those uh big name guys and
just getting around them i think is just
very beneficial for me and
can only help me out and you know take
my game to that that next level big
bobby tonyan what a pleasure to chat
with you on this show
i love hearing you know what you said
really hit me and i think everybody
should take this out
in their daily lives that what what uh
what you did last year when anybody had
a good year or a good day or a good day
at work
that is you you know what i mean like i
thought that what you just said is like
last year that is me
you know like you're gonna prove that is
me like that that that isn't
uh an anomaly that is me i i love that
man
good luck and being you i appreciate it
you guys appreciate that yeah i mean
rich i i i you know meeting you and down
in indianapolis and
being around you and the good that you
do off the field with everything
you know i appreciate you i love
watching what you do you're a legend
i appreciate you appreciate you uh
having me on the show i appreciate you
saying that let's do this more often
you and i that's george you got my
number now okay good yeah i'm not gonna
lose that i'll lose george's first
who the hell is george kittle how does
that sound is that all right
don't i'm not agreeing to that okay
i might have taken it too far all right
take care of yourself robert
have a good one richard you got that's
robert tunion everybody right here on
the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here